madeleine y su pequeño de nueve meses
acuden a un banco de alimentos para
recoger la comida que consumirán en la
semana
como ella cientos de personas dependen
de esta ayuda porque con el aumento de
los precios de los alimentos en un 63
por ciento los últimos 12 meses
les resulta imposible llenar la canasta
alimentaria
dinero de alcanza para nada vas a
comprar con una cantidad de dinero y no
te basta porque está todo todo con el
precio muy alto
es el efecto de la inflación que golpea
eeuu
en las familias se les hace muy difícil
y por lo tanto también digamos siempre
tenemos 950 familias que distribuíamos y
damos una bolsa muy grande tuvimos que
reducir porque no puede hay muchas cosas
que están muy caras realmente
esta dominicana y su pequeño de 9 meses
viven con su marido y su suegra en la
misma casa los cuatro tienen que llegar
a fin de mes con dos mil dólares antes
estoy va con cincuenta dólares y podías
comprar huevo carne un poquito queso y
verduras ahora no ahora vas con 50
dólares y apenas puedes comprar tal vez
dos verduras y un poquito de carne el
aumento del precio de la luz les ha
obligado a cambiar las rutinas la
televisión solo se enciende dos horas al
día y las luces casi siempre están
apagadas antes estábamos pagando 30 32
dólares
al mes ahora la factura está llegando de
60 a 70 75 dólares detrás de la
inflación dicen los expertos que hay
varios motivos entre ellos la escasez de
trabajadores la crisis energética y uno
importante falta de abastecimiento
provocada por esos atascos en las
cadenas de suministro
ginette ha sido testigo de cómo las
estanterías de este supermercado están
cada vez más vacías siempre ha sido así
ahora con la crisis se está vaciando eso
cuánto cuesta
si 9 kos y fuerte
casi 20 dólares por 4 kilos de pollo
según los economistas los precios están
cerca de alcanzar su punto máximo y a
partir de ahí comenzarán a estabilizarse
aunque también advierten que pasarán
meses hasta verse las mejoras